an instagram account has been set up to
help find people
still missing it has more than a hundred
thousand
followers the profile at locate victims
beirut has been sharing pictures of
missing people provided by their friends
and family
it helped the families identify a number
of victims receiving hospital treatment
who
are unable to speak tatiana has ruti
is a beirut resident her father works at
the port but
is amongst those missing and she joins
us now via skype tatiana i'm so sorry to
hear that your
father is missing tell me how did you
find out about that
thank you for having me first we
after the explosion happened our glass
and the house was shattered
every everything was very bad
we turned on the tv to see what happened
and they we saw that it was in the port
so we started calling baidad everybody
was calling us to see if
he's at work or he's at home and
nobody we didn't get a connection we
couldn't reach him and nobody told us
anything about him
until now we don't know anything about
him and we think he is trapped
under the rubbles of the buildings so
you
don't think that he's been taken to
hospital you've managed to check all the
hospitals in beirut
yes on tuesday we checked all the
hospitals we
we were divided into groups our family
started searching the hospitals if
somebody said they saw him or
they think he's the man there you
started going
calling and you're still calling till
now and nobody can give us anything
about him
what is the search and rescue effort at
the site where you believe your father
is trapped what do you know about that
going on there actually
no official authority told us anything
it's only us we went there they couldn't
let us go and
we only know that there are there is the
red red cross
the civil defense and the lebanese army
searching for them there
they didn't dig where we told them that
my father is
where he is and his colleagues they are
seven
workers at the silo they're trapped we
we think they are trapped actually and
we told them to dig
where they are and still nothing today
morning we got
a new a new news they told us that my
they are digging where my dad is okay so
you're waiting for news right now
yes why do you think all this happened
tatiana
i don't know why all this happened i
think it's much bigger than me
or any citizen here i think it's
something with the government
or some political party we don't really
know
but i do think that my dad and his
co-workers
are innocent they do not deserve this
they do not deserve this mask that that
we are
in all the families all beirut is gone
some people don't have a house now and
people
are on the streets we don't deserve this
we have a corrupted system and i think
it should be we deserve better than this
tatiana we very much hope that you will
be hearing some good news
today thank you very much for taking the
time to speak to us here on al jazeera